just a small percentage of women make up
law enforcement in departments Across
the Nation and here in Las Vegas an
annual event is hoping to help bring
more women to police departments
reporter Brian will shows us how the
Wonder Women of Metro event raising
awareness
[Music]
women only make up about 13 percent of
police officers Nationwide in Las Vegas
that number is about 14 percent women
have made such strides in so many
different places and there's some places
where it's simply harder for Captain
Michelle Tavares she's one of the few
women leading the way for other women to
join the ranks women bring a different
touch to law enforcement than men do you
know the world of Academia tells us that
women actually statistically get into
less use as a force than men do that
touch is being celebrated through this
event we have a support system we take
care of each other we have ways that we
can do it all and so that's why they
call it the Wonder Women of Metro this
is the sixth year of this event
celebrating women in law enforcement
during women's history month and
showcasing the women behind the badge
getting to come to events like this is
always a fun positive you know thing to
do and sometimes can be kind of a
difficult job the event hopes to attract
more women to the role we're trying to
pave the way for those coming behind us
to know that they can do it
now that event is put on by the Las
Vegas Metropolitan Police Department
Foundation a non-profit that raises
money to go to community engagement
programs